okay I've got another political update I
hope we don't have to do this every day
now but yesterday I made the big
announcement that in Los Angeles not
this weekend but next weekend I would be
debating alongside secular talks Kyle
kolinsky against a turning point USA's
Candace Owens and turning point USA's
charlie Kirk or possibly against Candace
Owens and Dan I think Bonjean oh yeah
Bungie no I'm sure I forgot his first
name was Dan it has been so hectic I
have been put on and taken off of like
three or four different things by
politican Kyle kolinsky was scheduled as
far as he knew to debate and Coulter
that has since been cancelled because
Ann Coulter decided she doesn't want to
do it so I already have to sort of take
a step back from what I told you
yesterday you know this is so crazy
on Monday night at 11:30 p.m. I was
texting with the politican people and
they said we've got this debate for you
on Sunday and I said I was planning to
fly home Sunday I'll change my flight is
this confirmed is it is this definitely
happening and they said it's absolutely
happening you Kyle
Candice Charlie Sunday at 3:00 p.m.
something like that Pacific time go
ahead and change your flight and I did
it and Kyle and I yesterday were texting
back and forth and we noticed that that
debate still wasn't listed on the
Politico new website and as of this
morning it still wasn't so I decided to
email politican and say I'm wondering
given that I changed my flight when
you're gonna list this thing on the
website and they said well we're listed
as soon as the panel is confirmed to
which I said at 11:30 p.m. last night
you told me it's confirmed change your
flight to which they said oh yeah the
panel's confirmed the panelists haven't
confirmed though yeah and I think
because they're calling it a panel a
conversation a discussion they think
they can just switch anybody in yeah
because you know debate implies that you
have to do some background research you
have to do a lot of preparation and you
certainly want to know your opponent a
couple weeks ahead of time yes but
because they're using these other words
these code words that allows them to get
around it so you know there's a sort of
obvious question which is if it turns
out that it's going
be David Pakman and Kyle kolinsky versus
third stringers from The Daily wire for
example was that worth changing my
flight when that's gonna require me to
miss a day of the show which I take
seriously every time that you know I'm
off that's a decision that we make we
take it seriously right we pay our guest
hosts it's not just hey whatever I'll
just change my flight and not show up so
quite frankly I don't know what's going
on I hope that Pakman and kolinsky
versus owens and kirk is happening
otherwise I hope it's Owens and Bonjean
Oh kolinsky and Pakman versus unknown
daily wired third stringers or something
like that is very much less interesting
to me and I don't know what's going on
at this point imagine if like another
organization did this like the NFL we
thought that the Patriots were gonna
play the Bears yeah Sunday at 3 o'clock
but in Subban they're playing the Lions
Monday night like you can't do that you
can't do it you can't do it you
shouldn't do it anyway and I'm just
telling you so why am I telling you this
today if you went out and bought a
ticket to fly to LA and bought a ticket
to politican on the basis that I was
participating in that debate and I know
people in our audience are doing that
and people in Kyle kolinsky audience are
doing that they're traveling across the
country for these events maybe you want
to wait because the panel is confirmed
but the panelists it's like when Trump
said what was it the story is real but
the news is fake or something like the
reporting is real but the news is fake
or something like that doesn't make any
sense right the panel is in be one or
the other yeah yeah it doesn't make any
sense
apology in advance if you booked a
non-refundable ticket and this ends up
not happening